c'est burkinabé viennent de tout perdre
des jihadistes pour t'attaquer leur
village la guerre qui fait rage depuis
six ans au mali le pays voisin s'étend
maintenant au burkina faso les conflits
qui se multiplient ont fait l'an dernier
3 millions de nouveaux réfugiés et
déplacés
longeant car on vivait tempête dit ce
paysan de 67 ans avant que les
terroristes arrivent lors de la dernière
attaque en mai on était au chant c'était
le sauve-qui-peut
mais on a tout perdu nos bêtes nous
maison notre argent tout marietta vient
du même village
il songe de nietzsche et de onze hommes
à bord et de noroise cas la procédure
c'est le cv premiers mois nous
intéressons pas tous la volonté nous
avec nos enfants
marietta issaka et des centaines
d'habitants de leur village vivent
depuis une semaine dans la cour de cette
école de la capitale en plein soleil
il manque d'eau de nourriture de
vêtements 60% des gens qui fuient les
violences se déplacent à l'intérieur de
leurs coûts
même scénario en république démocratique
du congo
les combats ont repris en et tueries
dans l'est est juste depuis le début du
mois de juin
trois cent mille congolais ont été
poussés sur le chemin de l'exil c'est
son 1000 par semaine le congo est
certainement des crises négligées comme
bien des crises qui s'étire sur une qui
se prolonge sur une longue période il ya
souvent beaucoup plus de visibilité au
début des conflits
il ya aussi plus de visibilité quand les
populations travers des frontières que
quand il reste au sein de leur propre
pays
temps mais ceux qui fuient les violences
au delà des frontières 80% se réfugie
dans un pays voisin un pays pauvre
la plupart du temps l'europe les états
unis dit il n'ont pas de crise de
réfugiés
ce qui en a que le plus sont à côté les
pays en guerre
c'est là qu'est la crise bath où elle le
croise des pertes matérielles que vivent
les gens quand ils sont déplacés et les
répercussions les plus graves et sont
effectivement psychologique c'est pas
juste ne pas pouvoir nourrir sa famille
donc c'est un énorme chamboulement dans
les visions des gens
le nombre de déracinés a doublé depuis
20 ans ça veut dire que des millions
d'afghans de palestiniens de ce malien
de congolais vivent presque toute leur
vie dans des camps privé de plusieurs
droits
quand on parle de gens qui sont pas
capables de gagner leur vie de façon
légale à tout le moins qui dans certains
cas ont pas le droit de s'installer à
l'extérieur deux camps de réfugiés donc
gédéon parle de contraintes extrêmement
important un réfugié peut sortir d'un
camp si sa demande d'asile est acceptée
par une autre pays
ils deviennent alors des réfugiés
réinstallés l'an dernier le canada a
accueilli 30 % de ces demandeurs c'est
le pays qui en a accueilli le plus grand
nombre et si sophie langlois radio
canada montréal